my girlfriend was looking forward to
this day the whole month hey what's up
my name is Matt Martin when the GQ
bathroom and we have three tips for
maintaining your facial hair while
growing a beard
if you don't moisturize your skin you
run the risk of breaking out but when
you're using soap in the shower the soap
is stripping the natural oils on your
skin which will essentially dry it out
so you're going to want to supplement
that with some moisturizer but it's
important to look for the oil-free
moisturizer otherwise you get really
greasy and nasty and you want to feel
like that the tiniest amount of hands
you can rub it through just kind of rub
it onto the beard hair you know cover
the skin and the and the follicles down
there and that's it it's really simple
and you'll feel good and go smell good
and it's about it I'm gonna show you
guys how to wear a mustache without
looking like a creep so when I'm shaving
with one of these like super fancy
futuristic razors here I like to go sort
of against the grain um you could shave
with the grain if you have an older
razor but with these newer ones it's
kind of like just easier to go against
it I don't like to leave too much
sideburn I don't want to go for this
rockabilly look so I like to shave a
little bit higher up with a point right
over here on my ear so the keys you
don't want it to go too far over the
corner of your lip I feel exactly like
my father right now I don't think I've
once seen him without a mustache I think
he was born out of the womb with one the
great thing about virtual hair is if you
mess up completely you can always start
over again in a couple of weeks oh I
didn't mess it up and all right one of
the risks I learned pretty early on
growing beard is that you're going to
have all this mess of growth you know
sort of around your neck and the way to
fix that is you fade your beard up from
the bottom so the first thing you're
going to need is a beard trimmer you
grab one of these that you know
basically any drugstore and you're gonna
grab one of the little guards that comes
with it you don't want the the super
tight trim you want a little bit of
extra room the the sort of dividing line
here is going to be your Adam's apple
anything that is below your Adam's apple
is fair game
shaving cream razor take it all down and
then you're going to imagine about an
inch above your Adam's apple
and that's where the trimmer comes in
you're going to take that line and go
about an inch up all the way around
so it's still covering the bottom of
your chin it doesn't have like a super
harsh sharp line there it looks natural
and then you clean it up down below
thanks for watching guys make sure you
go and subscribe to gqueues youtube
channel where we've got a whole bunch of
great grooming tips for you